all right ray-ray where you from
originally where'd you grow up
Oakland and tell me about your family
you grew up with both your parents yeah
a little while as a child they would uh
let me get drunk you know my father and
yeah a little job but when he get drunk
he's always beating another up you know
argue with her and do all kind of stuff
to it and me and my brother we just get
upset and then she would take it out on
us trying to get back at him and it was
terrible and sometimes my brother got
more left it one time getting end up get
killed behind it close no my father and
mother was fighting in Iran our street
and got hit by car where did these like
three years old
yeah so I end up heard of this dude that
ran over my mother brother later on I
end up shooting him nobody really knows
I did it but I had got a little revenge
and it bothers me a lot of science think
about it that I did it I kind of regret
it but he gave my if he killed my
brother's rent over in the car I mean my
little brother yeah I'm purpose or just
an accident accident probably most like
this but I just felt feel like that I
regret more grateful because that's the
thing it was an accident but I still did
it I feel guilty about it a lot of times
you know if going handle stuff like that
voices kind of time and the troubles
means those I wind up going to deal
right hospital boy you sure give me
medications but I couldn't I could never
tell them what I did it was really
bothering me the voices that her I found
her later
they must mine my dad here using them in
Oscars room my mother she was from Texas
she was a good woman till he started
really making a drink and used to make
my soul northern and we I to college
date him
you just put a car he put his car on the
flat just stuff like that but she used
to take it out on us just made me get in
the box
when I was little mad at him trying to
take it out on him you're just like him
make me get in the box
and staying there for hours sit mom
please don't let me get in the box
these dogs don't swim in the box maybe
stay in the box sounds little
it will because of him he's never had a
car in my life I had a unstable job
before but because of my conditions it's
hard for me to come and deal with people
like that
because I'm getting upset and I go back
into my old way of thinking murder I did
it once and I said I'll do it again
you know Keeney's yeah so now I'm older
now I'm still dealing with them I'm
homeless I stay away from all the people
that I used to know
well most of those have fallen off and
died and shot whatever the sick gone
away kale prison I still here but my
life is empty I we don't have a whole
lot of good times in life a lot of
suffering
without uneducated I wish I could've
been a lawyer doctor a judge or
something like that
I miss my mom
now that something I do something to
myself because of that discreet myself
want to die
I really think my life I think that's
the reason why maybe my life stay like
that
a lot of stuff that happened my mom he
died from from killing with my father
beating her and doing stuff to her
please use the treat me anything she
love me at all
we've got a page
love page
I don't how to deal with deal with it
we have no friends I can't have friends
or not have friends
we ended up getting the fight no
girlfriend and referring to like just
this they have two crazy
- straight to jail as to whatever
yep camera of one kid he's she took him
away I never really saw my saw a picture
he tells it she said it was my kids but
no not for sure she's ready Mike you're
not licensed we shall get us have a car
before they ever been able to kill your
car they've helped organize the
warehouse or permit
- like almost like of handicapped
acceptance
if there's one thing about your life
that you could have changed to change
your path and direction what do you
think that might have been that would be
do you still carry that with you to this
day yep
yeah yeah
I think someday somebody gonna shoot me
lots of this get either paranoid or
through so many things or take pills and
stuff trying to get stuff out of my head
how did you kill him gone pretty guy yep
holger you know slow change 13 years old
okay zone will be different with that of
58 now so it's ready to have a total of
my life if you don't mind
it's after dealing with abusive families
drunks lack of love
here's better hair clothes shoes
I don't there - hustle hustle up our
food because they mess money up
yeah well
so trodden
try those maybe get some counseling
that's right was they would only take
medications
Oh often time I think about committed
suicide suicide because of all of that I
was molested as a child
unless you what yes
so so just until my life is now above
this I have a little tip yeah try to
sleep it
are the real friends
these drugs to help you deal with any of
the stuff you went to the alcohol drugs
sometimes pills to date myself from the
voices
still here with - voice how did that
brother how does that be to be the boxes
enough stuff spin small barrels rubies
I think one day love they should think
bigger
find a media dollars and substance and
buy house and car baby get married
even in love before
yeah salafi
let's go for three years here finally
she met somebody else I could take care
of her
school
[Music]
pause my life like this other people's
sight they have good lives have the
family
I was thinking about [ __ ] suicides
lately that bothered me cause the pain
of my life
well to the out cuz the word I love
their kids with this freedom right jack
brother
this violet
apologize or the tears of pride stuff
hmm
although I will do
Oh
they'll try really hard though to deal
with it nobody really cares Bush had to
share a great story with you and that's
just paper right
that's good we live all right well thank
you for coming in and sharing your story
thank you good nephew
you